i just wanted to uh ask you in regards
to
the balance now you're
winning awards and you're also now
rising as a mogul
and not just music but in business
so if you could take me into
achieving this balance now that you're
holding an award as well
yeah i mean you know i think when i hit
the scene it was um
you know we kind of came out of the box
with with hicktown which was a you know
big up tempo banger and
you know we
to me it was something that was i was
kind of conscious of from the beginning
that's why we released you know wise the
second single kind of a slower ballad
and then amaryllis guy like i wanted to
like i love those big up tempo songs but
i've always
loved the balance too you know and and
so i feel like over the last few years
we've um
i don't know we just we've found some
badge recorded some things that were
just
really big songs you know from you make
it easy and got what i got and some of
these things and so um it's hard to to
not record those things and put them out
when you feel like they're such great
songs so i've always kind of been open
to it i've always kind of been
you know aware of the fact that i never
wanted to paint myself into a corner
like that and uh
and two you know when you're in the
business this long
you know if you keep doing the same
thing it's gonna get old after a while
so you gotta gotta balance it out and
change it up every now and then and so
uh i feel like that's kind of been
something that's probably happened more
a little later in my career now but uh
but you know i love it i love singing
those songs on stage and it's kind of
helped to balance it all out like you
said
uh kristen hall with ap um i wanna ask
about the performance tonight because i
feel like you and carrie really based it
up i mean with her coming down and you
at the piano like tell me what your
thoughts were for that performance i was
scared for her actually when
when we came to rehearsals i was like i
knew she was coming from the ceiling but
i was like where is she sitting and then
they showed me this little bitty seat
and i'm like oh man so i went to her i'm
like man i'm glad you're doing this and
not me because i would have tapped out
so
she's uh she's a trooper for sure but
you know definitely we've done this song
now a few times at some different award
shows and you know trying to find ways
to to change it up a little bit and do
something we haven't done and so uh
it's uh that was kind of the idea and um
so it you know it worked out good it
looked like you know like i said a
little bit of a vegas show but one i was
nervous the whole time until she got on
the ground i was like all right we're
good but uh but it was
fun
stephen from abc we know now that carrie
was the surprise yeah
um you've had such a great track record
with male female duets with carrie and
miranda and kelly
is there any desire in you to to
continue that string with either one of
them and do a george and tammy thing do
you feel that chemistry with any of them
i mean i feel like i've had chemistry
with all of them you know as far as as
vocal you know in the studio vocal wise
um
but you know i think for me it kind of
depends on the song you know it kind of
depends on
on the song and sort of what voice i
hear you know with drowns of whiskey it
was miranda was kind of a no-brainer you
know for me it was a little more on the
countryside and
um
don't you want to stay and and now this
one you know a little bit more of the on
the pop side so you know kind of felt
like we needed a big vocalist for those
and
at the time kelly was the one that i
kind of heard on that song carrie was
the one for this one so i don't know man
i mean i love working with with all of
them and i love working with other
artists in general but
uh obviously uh we've had some big
success with with those three in
particular and and so i'm definitely
down to do it again i don't want to like
reach the point where we do it too much
but uh but if something comes up we feel
like it's the right song i would you
know definitely reach out to them again
for sure
jason john katzelomitos with the las
vegas review journal all right welcome
back thank you um
we've seen you perform a couple of times
here in las vegas since route 91
and um i'm just wondering how you feel
about uh
now about being part of our city's
history and if you've resolved your
relationship
with with las vegas in relation to that
event yeah you know i mean it's uh
you know not quite the way i wanted to
to be attached to the city by any means
but uh i do feel a special
uh connection to to the city and
and um
more so since since route 91
um
but you know i mean it's i enjoy coming
back here man i always had a great time
being here some of the highlights of my
career happened
in this town at this particular show um
so i have a lot of great memories from
here i always enjoy coming back you know
with the exception of the one time it
was it's always been great so
um you know i think for me it's
something that
obviously we you know we think about a
lot and probably always will but um but
you know i feel like
for me personally i'm kind of at peace
with everything and and just uh you know
trying to try to move on and and you
know make the best of a bad situation
and and
you know that's kind of all you can do i
feel like
great we got one question from our
virtual press room uh dan van from
albright o'malley brunner country music
jason congrats on this award well
deserved thank you man
the question is is when it comes to
touring you're going to be going out
with gabby barrett this coming year is
your thought process that when you pick
somebody to go out on tour with you that
maybe there's a possibility that you
could maybe do something with them in
the future because you do do a lot of
duets with a lot of the people that you
work with yeah you know i mean i i think
gabby's uh
super talented i mean i think she's one
of the you know best female singers we
got that's sort of coming up right now
and so
um
just kind of a fan of what she you know
what i heard of hers and i wanted to to
try and get her locked up for the tour
which we were able to do and um you know
i don't know there's no plans as of
right now it kind of goes back to what i
was saying earlier i mean
to me i kind of let the song
steer the ship a little bit you know
it's
if we find a song that i feel like would
work for her and
that
you know i feel like she would
she would do something that i felt like
was something specifically for her i
would absolutely love to work work with
her at some point um i'm just i'm always
kind of open to that with anybody you
know whether it be
males or female acts
so i don't know you know it's it's not
why we brought her out there i'm just
i'm a fan of what she does i wanted to
to bring her out on the road with us but
you know i'm like i said i'm open to all
that stuff always